[Music]
you
[Music]
let's talk about democracy for a minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
yeah yes yesterday yes yesterday
yes yesterday
yester
yesterday
yesterday
is not a hard word you [ __ ] loser
yesterday is not a hard word
we watch the crybaby in chief on his
outtakes
did you know that jared kushner was
taking a [ __ ] shower while the coup
was going on
during the coup jared kushner apparently
was taking a shower
he said i had to turn the shower off
what
i guess i guess you he had to go wash
all the sedition off
it's kind of filthy
what the [ __ ] taking a shower during the
coup
i guess he was getting all cleaned up
for when they took power and he was
gonna be the prince of the united states
of america or some [ __ ] i don't know
this is [ __ ] weird this is weird
i think it's weird
the hearings last night did not
disappoint
i was wondering
and i was thinking about the steve
bannon part
we watched that steve bannon audio
inside the room of donors
just a few days before the election
where he's saying donald trump is going
to declare himself the winner and it
doesn't matter how bad he loses that's
how we're gonna win as he's gonna steal
it who gives a [ __ ] basically
that [ __ ] traitor
but that released several days before
this hearing i was thinking about that
this morning
because steve bannon is in court today i
think i think he's in court today i
haven't checked
he should be in court every [ __ ] day
but i digress from that
that tape from steve bannon can you
imagine if
no one had heard that tape before last
night and they played that live to the
nation
everyone went by oh holy actual [ __ ]
that would have been groundbreaking
my my wonder is because mueller she
wrote allison
she tweeted earlier
then it's possible that steve bannon may
use that as a defense
that they're trying to taint a jury pool
the select committee were to taint a
jury pool so i was thinking about that
and i thought well maybe she's on to
something here
maybe she's on to something
and it's not that maybe i'm not that
steve bannon wouldn't use every single
angle that he possibly could but as i
said yesterday and last night i believe
we were on air with adam parkamingo when
i said
steve bannon is not trying all kinds of
tactics inside this trial
because when he goes before the judge
to be sentenced that magistrate will use
the those tactics that he's trying to
use in court against him in his
sentencing
because steve bannon can be sentenced up
to two years he probably is expecting to
be found guilty and to be sentenced to a
prison term here
that's probably what he's expecting now
rather we actually see that or not you
know only time will tell here and we're
not going to have to take too much time
i don't think
within the next week or so we'll know if
he's get charged or convicted excuse me
and it may take a while a month or so
for the sentencing but they may try to
sentence him almost right away
just depends on the federal court
federal court is a lot slower sometimes
but what i'm trying to get at here is
maybe maybe someone leaked that ban in
audio
to make sure that he didn't have that
defense
and maybe that was a huge piece of the
bombshell that was supposed to happen
that we actually didn't get a huge
ripple
from that video or that audio as it were
that we may have otherwise
because it was released prior
but the one the one thing everyone is
latching on to this morning from the
hearing
is that josh hawley is a little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what a [ __ ] what a god damn weak little
piece of [ __ ] josh holly is
to go out in front of the trump crowd
and pretend like he's [ __ ] tough
pumping his fist sending his nazi sign
and really honestly i've said this
several times josh hawley if you're
listening
when you do the nazi salute you really
gotta stretch your arm out and get your
fingers out straight
it's not a fist it's more of you know
the fingers out
dumb [ __ ]
but this guy going and round right
rounding up the crowd getting them all
ready to go commits insurrection
and the minute the minute he realizes
that those same same brainless zombies
those trumpets
those let's go brandon nazis decide to
enter into the capital he runs like a
little scared [ __ ]
what was it that trump called pence did
he call him a [ __ ] i don't know i'm
just saying and i think rudy giuliani
called him a [ __ ] too
hmm
maybe those words are appropriate here
for josh holly
what in the actual [ __ ]
when i was watching because they didn't
have the room miked during the video
okay so what happened was during the
production
they would turn the mics off in the room
to play the tape during the production
so none of the mics in the room were
picking up any of the sound
so when we were watching on the screen
you could just see the video and hear
the audio from the video
no audio from the room
but when it cut back to the room and
sarah matthews
it showed her face on screen
and she was laughing and the people
behind her were laughing
i thought oh my god they're all laughing
at him
that was that was because i was laughing
at him that was my immediate reaction
when i saw that video
when that little scared little punk was
running
running for his life
after he after he incited them he helped
incite them not just not just with the
fist pump you gotta remember this
[ __ ] was on fox news weeks
before almost every single day talking
about how trump had a legal path to
become president
and mike pence was that legal path
and josh hawley was gonna stall this
thing until mike pence decided that
donald trump was king
and they [ __ ] believed him
they [ __ ] believed him
because that's what they wanted to
believe they wanted to believe
donald trump they wanted to believe josh
hawley they wanted to believe ted cruz
mo brooks marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert all the cuban honors they wanted
to believe it because if they didn't
believe that they had to believe that
their orange mussolini jesus really is a
super [ __ ] loser
and this morning as we wake up as the
nation
is going to use this information
in our social structure here
and you better politicize the hell out
of this
my audience better go politicize the
ever-loving [ __ ] out of this information
that was presented to the american
people last night
it's crucial to our democracy
because that's exactly what it was
designed to do is to destroy our
democracy
that fat [ __ ] sat in the dining room and
watched those people smear [ __ ] on our
walls in the capitol
he watched as they were going to kill
mike pence and he didn't give a [ __ ]
pat cipolloni you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
last night
there was no
i have no more respect
for pat sipoloni [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
and liz cheney said it at the end
two young women two young women who have
the rest of their lives the rest of
their careers in front of them if they
want to be republican which they claim
they are
very republican very conservative
cassie hutchinson and sarah matthews
those two women stood against the
fascist donald trump and his allies
last night
and when cassidy hutchinson
testified in open public
and patsy baloney it took
it took just him thinking he may have
criminal liability
to come in and speak on videotape so
they could play it
and even then that weak [ __ ]
invoked privilege where he doesn't he
doesn't need to invoke privilege give me
a [ __ ] break
you need to invoke privilege when you're
standing there talking about how you had
a conversation with your boss
our office holder the president of the
united states in a room
when you're having a conversation about
him killing the vice president of the
united uh
standing by
while the vice president gets killed
by the mob that he incited to go kill
him
and you're going to invoke privilege
when they ask you
who in the room didn't want them to stop
to go kill mike pence
you're going to invoke privilege you
weak piece of [ __ ]
and this only goes to show you and i've
been saying it
and i'll pound this drum over and over
and over again conservatism
fascism
the far right are weak [ __ ]
they're [ __ ]
weak
liberalism is what is strong
liberalism is tough
it's gritty
it has to be
liberal democracies can't survive
without toughness
they'll sink into autocracy
almost instantaneously without a fight
this idea that liberals and liberalism
is weak is [ __ ]
and i'm not talking about big l liberals
that people
self identify themselves politically as
a liberal i'm talking about liberal
western democracy freedom liberty rights
written constitutional law
our republic
liberal democracy is what is tough
that's why they keep screaming about
christian nationalism because they want
authoritarianism because it's easy
it's easy for them to tell us what to do
and then use the state to force us to do
it rather it's to believe what to do
what not to do who to do who not to do
when you can and cannot have medical
procedures what you can and cannot learn
whether you they want you to know the
truth or lies
that's [ __ ] easy
liberalism is hard
liberal democracy is hard
that's why we have to fight for every
single inch every single millimeter here
and last night was a it's a correct step
in that direction when adam kinzinger
which i agree with on very little
very little do i agree with with
kenzinger
but last night when he said that an
event like this
does not define how bad a democracy is
on the other side of it it's what you do
about that thing that makes your
democracy good or bad strong or weak
and what we are doing right now is the
strength of our democracy
to come together
we the people
to push forward past this dark age of
our history
where we fought and screamed about some
ladies emails
elected a [ __ ] man baby a crybaby a
little baby back [ __ ] to be our
president
who is a criminal a [ __ ] criminal
and every move he makes he thinks like a
criminal
and we allowed him to have three picks
on the supreme court
and have the reins of our government to
try to destroy it from within
and we are dealing with that today
with the overturning of roe v wade
possibly some overturning of of our
voting rights
by this [ __ ] bought and paid for
fascist supreme court
this morning schedule f is trending
an executive order that donald trump
wrote to basically spread his trumpism
disease deep inside of our government
and we must not let that happen
we
as a democracy as pro-democracy people
have to spread the message that these
people want to destroy
our way of life
they want to destroy it
your community your church your school
they want to destroy it that's what they
want
they want to break it apart into pieces
jesus christ betsy devos last week who
is the secretary of education said it
should be
abolished that the federal government
should have no oversight on education
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
us we the people
we do not get to have oversight over
education in this country get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] that's what
they want folks
they've done this for decades and
decades and decades and talked about big
government and scared everyone with big
government
what they want is a fascist state to
tell you what the [ __ ] to do what the
[ __ ] to think
it has always been projection
always been projection it's not big
government
to organize as a as a as a society to
make sure we're the most educated that
we possibly can be
and hopefully the the highest educated
society on the face of the planet
we can do that we the people the
government can do that
they don't want us to do that
what they want to use government for is
to tell you what you can and can't do
with your genitalia who and who you can
and cannot love
who you can and cannot marry
what you can and cannot name your kids
who you can and cannot identify as
they want to make sure the strike fear
in your hearts when you go to the
grocery store when you send your kids to
school when you go to a concert
when you show up at a shopping mall that
some [ __ ] crazy loon is gonna [ __ ]
mow you down with a goddamn gun
that's what their idea of government is
and that is big government
authoritarianism you talk about some big
[ __ ] government
big [ __ ] government i mean they
aren't even going to let women cross
state lines without giving them a
pregnancy test at this point
that's not big government
they're tracking women's periods and
and cell phone apps that's not big
government get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] liberalism is tough
authoritarianism fascism conservatism as
they've thin veiled it for [ __ ]
decades is weak
and we saw that weakness on display
last night
when donald trump was weak
because he had lost
and he was sore about it
and he was scared what was to come if he
wasn't the president of the united
states
so he did the thing that weak white men
do
they try to retain power any means
necessary
whether it be crime violence or death he
didn't give a [ __ ] especially if it
wasn't him
and to have no remorse not a [ __ ] not
even a [ __ ] grain of rice of remorse
after the fact
only still thinking about himself
on the seventh in those outtakes
i don't wanna say i lost
i don't to say i lost
you poor [ __ ] baby
we are at a moment in history
where we can band together regardless of
your background
your race your religion
where you come from
what your ideology is
we are at a moment in history where we
can band together as a country
behind one ideal
and one ideal is all we need
that's all we need is just one one idea
and that's democracy
that's it that's all we need
on september 11th in 2001
several planes
hit buildings in new york killed
thousands of people hit buildings
building in washington dc the pentagon
and brave people took a plane down in
pennsylvania that killed everyone on the
plane killing thousands and thousands of
people
and this country looked at each other
and had one idea
and one idea only
we need to make sure this never happens
again
and we made a lot of mistakes
a lot of mistakes were made
and we made them for years
after we looked at each other behind one
idea
but this ideal democracy
as tough as it is as hard as it is
it's worth it
to look to each other and say yes we are
pro-democracy
our republican friends our moderate
friends are independent friends
even our friends that don't necessarily
like the democrats
on our side
we can get behind this one ideal
it's all we need
because this
this is the most important election that
we're going to have
in 2022.
there's a lot at stake not just the
senate and the house of representatives
they're secretary of states there's
governors they're state legislators
their city council
there's school board
there's county commissions there's mayor
races
there's prosecutors and judges
it all matters folks it all matters
because fascism is knocking at the door
and american fascism this christian
nationalism this this
fascism in a maga hat trumpism
is still here and the disease still
exists in our democracy
and it's trying to kill our democracy
from within
so i implore you
engage in your ballot don't just mark
your ballot engage in it register people
to vote
use your talent whatever it may be if
you're really good at texting compact
contact campaign see if you can text
form texting campaigns
see if you can talk on the phone leave
voicemails write letters
postcards
if you got a little extra cash there's
plenty of campaigns out there that are
gonna need the money to beat these
fascists
it takes money to knock on doors
it's hotter than a [ __ ] right
now these door knockers out there need a
lot of water and some fuel
so help those campaigns whether you're
knocking doors or helping pass out water
and stay vigilant for our democracy
because that's the thing that we have to
as america as americans
as neighbors as friends as family
that is the idea that we can get around
there is seems to be
an anti-democratic insurgency in this
country with this christian nationalism
so-called christian
nationalism
and it is beginning to develop as a
small insurgency
and these hearings and the truth about
january 6
will break people down and break them
apart
from this insurgency trust me it will
work
but we have to do the work we can't just
rely on everyone
seeing the hearings or hearing the
entirety
you have to talk about it you have to
engage in it one great way is some of
these little quippy moments the ketchup
the secret service that he couldn't say
yesterday josh holly running away from
the mob that he helped in sight
these little moments these little
moments
are what can get
that engagement started
and we must do it for our country
and for our democracy and for our future
and our children's future
you you want your children your
grandchildren to grow up in trump's
stand
that's what's at stake here
that's what's at stake because it's not
it's well beyond trump at this point
it's well beyond him
and we must stay vigilant because
there's other
there's other fascists waiting in the
wing
to take these people under their arm and
tweet them into another violent
insurrection
and to kill more public servants
that were doing their duty and doing
their job and filling their oath
maybe more that can't say the word
yesterday
[Laughter]
we got a lot of video to watch today
we're gonna go to the [ __ ] list roundup
and you know it's friday
and you know what we do in the second
hour and if you don't know if you're a
new listener here on the tony michaels
podcast every single friday in the
second hour we go through bonehead of
the week
here's what happens with bonehead you
get to go over to
twitter at the tony michael's pod and
vote every single week for bonehead of
the week you vote
you decide me and my co-host gabe
sanchez break it down in the second hour
every single friday
your vote we break it down in bonehead
of the week so stick around for that in
the second hour
but when we come back when we come back
we will go to the [ __ ] list roundup also
make sure to subscribe to the tony
michaels podcast do not forget to hit
that subscribe button you do not want to
miss a thing also download every single
episode on apple spotify and google and
if you would for me please
if you got apple podcast go over to
apple podcast and give us some good
reviews we had some trolls
go over there and give us some bad
reviews
so go over and give us a five star
review if you can we really appreciate
it here at the tony michaels podcast
stick around right after this break
we will go to the [ __ ] list roundup
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another
up moment we're back to the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
we're gonna go surf the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
because i got a lot of video that i want
to show you from yesterday now the bone
head of the week is in the second hour
and i know we'll go throughout some of
the video there
but i still have a lot of video i want
to show you
um
something that happened outside the
capitol
or the the hearing building as it were
in washington
something happened that happened after
the hearing with a bunch of i don't know
q and honors or some [ __ ] i'm not sure
what these people are who they are i'm
not really sure
but let's do this let's go to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends for the
shitless roundup start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the tony michaels podcast we have
reached the part of the show where we
round up all the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends in the [ __ ] list roundup
oh my god after yesterday i'd get six
hours of [ __ ] i can round up
absolutely
oh my gosh
that hearing some of the the the outtake
and we're gonna watch the outtake i
believe we're gonna watch the outtake
and bonehead of the week
um it's about two minutes long it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's hilarious how
much of a whiny little [ __ ] he is
i didn't i didn't get mad at the secret
service and i didn't throw ketchup on
the wall
well there it is on video him throwing a
little fit over a few words words like i
lost
i'm i'm a loser
because he can't handle it he just can't
handle it
[ __ ] little [ __ ]
okay well let's go let's go to the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
cause there's a lot of stuff going on
this morning but i got a few videos i
want to show you um one of them is uh
josh holly run holly run is our theme
today and we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna talk and watch more about
this as it goes on but uh might just
touch
and i was i think i think uh
they they put this video when i was
producing the show last night
so i didn't actually see it till this
morning uh but this is oh my god this is
hilarious he put run holly run so he
kind of stole i stole the i stole the
name yeah what are you gonna do i stole
the name
i'm not it's in tribute
of this video because this is hilarious
i couldn't stop watching this this
morning i played it over and over and
over and over again and i got the music
stuck in my head i got the imagery stuck
in my head
but this is what midas touch put
together
from the midas touch network broadcast
here is here is run ollie run
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
what great art that is now if anyone is
is confused about josh hawley and his
involvement in the insurrection not only
is he the piece of [ __ ] that stood
outside and tried to to incite the crowd
with his little nazi fist in the air his
half-assed hal hitler jan gesture
but josh hawley is one of the first
senators who even who even publicly
acknowledged the possibility
that mike pence could overturn the
election and there could be there could
be alternative electors and who knows
what could happen
that's who that [ __ ] is
he's a seditionist
he's a seditionist
and he continues to do this [ __ ] and
last week we watched as josh hawley was
made a fool of
by a professor
she called him out on his transphobia
right in a hearing got it on record that
he was being transphobic it was
absolutely fantastic
there should be more of it
of that kind of behavior towards
senators like this seditionist
so thank you
for putting that video together of
course josh hawley is trending like
crazy this morning because of this even
on even on right right leaning radio
stations this morning in missouri
in missouri on right-leaning radio
stations this morning the news is that
josh huntley was running away from the
insurrectionist
i'm not kidding you
in missouri
red red deep red trump country
of missouri
they are airing on right-wing style
radio that josh holly was a scared
little scared little boy running away
from the insurrectionists that he
incited
and it's not like they're trying to
frame it up to where it's a good thing
not even close not even close now i'm
gonna go to uh what jordy my zelda said
everyone was
some people were upset last night that i
muted jordy's mic so i'm gonna give
jordy some time here and if jordy's
listening now jordy
this is a great tweet worst sketcher
commercial ever
i don't know do you think josh holly
wears sketchers i don't know i think
maybe where's crocs it's possible
now thank you jordy for your tweet and i
apologize
to team jordy out there
[Music]
for meeting jordy's my jordy knows it's
all in good fun it's all in good fun
thank you for joining us last night
jordy
um you and your drink and your popcorn
we always appreciate when we have jordy
on the show he needs to come on the show
more actually as a matter of fact he
should come on right now
he should come on right now so i can
publicly apologize to jordy give me just
a second let me see if i can
get jordy on on
let's see if we can we can get
we can get him on here
everyone's mad at me
that i muted jordy so i'm not i'm not
going to mute him i'm not going to mute
him this time i won't mute him we'll
we'll let him um
we'll let him come on air here
if i can get him he may be busy i don't
know i i pinged him so we'll see we'll
see where jordy is and if he can join us
if he does i'll bring him in and we'll
do apology live on air
[Laughter]
he says he says he's he says he's uh
elbow deep in his um
in his um
in his food right now so he won't be
able to join us right now so maybe maybe
we'll come back to to jordy to jordan
getting us some now let's see what what
else oh here is another thing that last
night we talked during the hearing uh
coverage uh ben mizelis brought this up
at the end this was the house
republicans tweeting
this is their official account
this isn't some kind of parody account
or some [ __ ] this is their actual real
account here the house republicans were
tweeting they never show what president
trump said peacefully
even they put quotes around it
even they put
go down peacefully
to the capitol
and take over the government peacefully
you know what i'm saying wink
even they even they put the quotes
around it jesus christ and they don't
they also why don't they have secret
service agent testifying that's the
reason why they don't have a secret
service agent testifying is because all
those secret service agents are
lawyering up right now because they're
in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] because now there's
a criminal probe
now there's a criminal probe
they tweeted all hearsay
it's on video
he can't say yesterday it's on video
stories not facts
when is the house democrats prime time
hearing on inflation they've been having
uh hearings on inflation dummies where
you been
the administration has been
doing things about inflation also gas
prices which has caused gas prices to go
down which has caused crude to drop
where you been oh that's right you were
planning the next coup
you [ __ ]
house republicans also tweet in real
time when does the congressional hearing
start for joe biden's 787
680 minutes of inaction over securing
our southern border
they complain that joe biden is seizing
thousands and thousands of pounds of
fentanyl yeah the word seized
they seized it
they're securing our border the other
thing the other thing house republicans
that you may have missed while you were
trying to overthrow our government still
is that the president actually went to
mexico and they got a deal to make sure
mexico is helping pay for border
security
you know like you guys in 2016 we're
having big huge nazi rallies screaming
and yelling that you wanted mexico to
pay for a wall mexico is actually
helping pay for border security now
to secure that border
and it wasn't trump that did that you
dumb [ __ ]
it was the guy you're complaining that
isn't and has inaction of sin securing
the border get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
what a bunch of boneheads every last
[ __ ] one of these people
and this the people who believe this
drivel this nonsense
this ridiculousness they want to believe
it
they want to believe it
they want to believe it
they want to
believe it
that's why when people say well is this
going to change minds it's not going to
change the minds of people who already
want to believe this stuff
let me show you a video here that
patriot takes put out from oan
i'm here here i i this is
patriot take says unhinged one america
news
our oan anchor allison steinberg
suggests joe biden's covet is a false
flag
to perhaps get people to accept vaccine
boosters or to install kamala harris as
president this is bone-headed type [ __ ]
we've we've
showed videos of this [ __ ] bonehead
here on our show
of nasty stupid vile racist [ __ ]
transphobic anti-gay [ __ ] she says
out in san diego as she's making social
media videos
this is allison steinberg this is their
their anchor
on their news station they even call it
news they call it news
what
listen to this vile piece of [ __ ] spew
out
just nonsense
and you can't look away at this
but i'm gonna tell you why
why they
this is a good example
of why they're still believing this [ __ ]
watch i thought the whole fist bump
charade was done in an effort to make
minimal contact maybe if jojo had been
wearing his diaper like a good little
boy he could have avoided all this and
yes i'm referring to his face diaper not
his regular diaper we all know joey
doesn't leave the basement without his
depends
it is real funny
what's funny is
everyone made those jokes about trump
way before they were making those jokes
about biting because it's true
because it's the truth see that's what's
that's what's that's what's funny
is when you point something out
that is that is true and then you
exaggerate the truth allison maybe you
should take a take a study day and
figure out what the [ __ ] comedy is
bonehead
i wouldn't be shocked if after this the
cdc decided to take this overreach
another step further and start trying to
mandate hazmat suits for everyone here's
the q anon conspiracy theories right in
your face
after she's really got all the white
trumped-up white men the fragile lonely
white dudes out there watching this
garbage
after she's got they got them all hopped
up on the diaper talk about joe biden
now she's going to feed them up and
shovel cueing on conspiracy theories
down their goddamn throats that would
actually make way more sense if they
want this failing garbage narrative of
theirs to remain somewhat believable if
you're going to enforce unconstitutional
mandates why not just go all in forget
the n95 let's go for full-on gas masks
to complement our disposable orange
jumpsuits
okay but jokes aside oh great jokes
hahaha funny [ __ ] funny [ __ ] allison
you're almost as funny as alex stein
on the capitol steps sexually harassing
aoc that's hilarious
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] idiot
this was written she wrote this somebody
wrote this [ __ ] wrote this garbage
and she's trying to she's trying to spew
it out in front of the camera
allison you know if you're really good
at this if you were really that good
you wouldn't need someone to write this
[ __ ] [ __ ] for you
you could [ __ ] it out of that pie hole
that you have without a goddamn script
i'm curious to know what you all make of
this is biden coming down with a china
virus an orchestrated stunt to scare
people into believing the new extra
deadly omicron variant is here so they
can blame the unbacks and push more jabs
oh yeah that's exactly what's happening
allison
that's exactly what's happening
that's what you [ __ ] would do
you would you would invent some kind of
crisis some kind of nonsense some kind
of [ __ ] that ain't coupled to any
type of reality and tethered to reality
at all
to scare people and get people to do
something that's why they say biden is
doing it because that's what they would
do that's what they have done that's
what they're going to continue to do
because they're a bunch of ninja poop
nazis they're fascist that's what
fascists do
is it perhaps conveniently timed along
with the impending climate crisis to
prime us for upcoming future lockdowns
is it a ploy to oust biden and install
the first black what is a woman
president
what in the [ __ ] what in the [ __ ] is she
talking about when she says lockdowns
want lockdowns
i have not heard of any [ __ ] look i
live in [ __ ] missouri
in trump country
we haven't had a goddamn lockdown since
may of 2020
and it's the people here who believe we
have lockdowns
and they haven't been locked down since
may
of 2020
may
of 2020
over two years ago these people were out
spreading around this [ __ ] virus like
it was goddamn skittles
the [ __ ] out of here lockdowns and then
and then the racist ass [ __ ] at the end
about kamala harris
but here's what i said
and this is the truth
this is exactly why
the question is well how can these
people believe this stuff
they want to believe it
and they want to believe it so much
that they'll listen to this bonehead say
it and here's why
i said this morning and this is the
truth this is the truth of the matter
this is highly effective with lonely
fragile trumped up white men
and that's exactly why it exists
reason why this stupid [ __ ] content
this stupid [ __ ] this drivel this
vile racism
this what about ism this projection
of their own fascism
exists is because lonely fragile trumped
up white men
absolutely love it they love it
and it's highly effective
just like
when people were going to try to tell
the president
to stop the siege stop the violence
it took his daughter to go in and
compliment him and tell him how great he
did
to get him to [ __ ] stop jesus christ
during the [ __ ] outtakes of the
statement on the seventh to make sure he
made the statement they had ivanka there
to guide him through
because he's a lonely fragile trumped up
white dude
and that's why this kind of garbage
[ __ ] exist
is because they exist
in our society
we should call them out
every single moment just like this video
here
uh will
staken has it from
just outside the hearing room
uh officer fatone one of the officers
that was beaten that day one of the
officers that actually came to the ver
one of the very first public hearings
that january 6 had
they're harassing him spreading lies
about him internet conspiracy theories
he does the right thing he walks away
but watch as someone tries to make sure
to stand in between these harassers
and officer fatone watch it's hilarious
watch what happens
why were you there january 6 you were
not even on tv why were you there
january
here's the guy with the signs
oh my god
i can't help but i can't stop this is
hilarious at the very end this old man
with the sign he
he comes in to stand in between uh the
end of the pvc pipe that is holding the
sign uh touches the man's arm and the
man falls right down over the little
planter wall there
oh
help me help me
this reminds me of trump
it really does this reminds me of trump
here's why
is that as soon as soon as as truth
which is the the old man holding the
sign here that is held with the pvc
pipes
as soon as the truth comes in and you
just get a whiff of the truth just a
whiff of the truth
you cry like a little [ __ ] baby
let's watch again
oh i did not he faked it
oh
the truth hurts
the truth the truth hurts you [ __ ]
you trumped up white snowflakes the
truth hurts
it hurts like a [ __ ] i was
pissed oh they pushed me he he touched
me with his pole
he he grazed my arm with his pvc pipe
what a [ __ ] oh my god but shame on
these people shame on these people and
look look look at what happens at the
very end i want you to notice here i'm
gonna slow this down now this guy is
pushed down
when when officer fatone realizes this
guy is pushed down and he's hurting and
the police officers are gonna go
look what he does look what immediately
he does
his instinct is to go try to figure out
what has happened
and he walks up to try to figure out
what happened to this guy the guy who
was a rant just just harassing him
that is officer fatone
so good luck to your narrative there
you
friggin idiots
okay let's let's
if
my internet is
there we go okay
move on here
okay let's see what else do we have that
we want to go through
oh yes here's another video
of his refusal
by sarah matthews as she describes here
to the committee about his refusal
what was your reaction to president
trump's message to the mob at 470
i was struck by the fact that he chose
to begin the video by pushing the lie
that there was a stolen election
and as the video went on i felt a small
sense of relief because he finally told
these people to go home
but that was immediately followed up by
him saying we love you you're very
special
and that was disturbing to me because
he didn't distinguish between those that
peacefully attended his speech earlier
that day and
those that we watched cause violence at
the capitol
instead
he told the people who we had just
watched
storm our nation's capital
with the intent on overthrowing our
democracy violently attack police
officers and chant heinous things like
hang mike pence we love you you're very
special
and
as a spokesperson for him i knew that i
would be asked to defend that and
to me
his refusal to act and call off the mob
that day and his refusal to condemn the
violence
was indefensible and so
i knew that i would be resigning that
evening and so i finished out the work
day went home and called my loved ones
to tell them of my
decision so there you have it
she had to call her
i'm not sure
sorry my
hang on just one second
there we go i have different things
playing in my ear i apologize
oh boy oh boy i'm gonna get hell for
this when when gabe comes on i'm sure
just not running it the way i should be
there is sarah matthews talking about
how she was going to resign right
afterwards
um
we're going to play the tape of trump
later but i also want to go to here is
the audio from inside the room um where
josh holly they played the josh hawley
video
uh here we go here is the now again
again as i said earlier in in the
monologue
in the front rant i don't know what it's
called i guess it's a model i guess
front ramp whatever you want to call it
the first 30 minutes of the show
josh holly
when they played the tape of him running
the room was not miked at that point
they shut the mics off in the room to
let the audio
from the tape play through the
production
so we didn't hear
from the production side
the room's response to the video
but this is a recording of the room
you see there's a lot of cell phones up
here this is recording of the room so
you can hear the room's response
when they play
the video of josh holly running for his
life
obviously the rumors thinks it's
hilarious
[Music]
when they watch
tough man masculine man anti-porn
porn's the problem we need more manly
men in this country josh holly run for
his life
from an insurrection that he incited of
course they thought it was funny
of course they thought it was funny
you couldn't i was laughing out loud
when it happened on screen
and again i could not hear in my ears
the production i couldn't hear
the sound from the room because it
wasn't mike but when it flashed back up
and you you saw the face of sarah
matthews and the people in the crowd
laughing you could see them physically
laughing you couldn't hear them but see
them physically laughing i'm like oh my
god
they're all laughing in the room at josh
holly and that is the news this morning
is that josh holly
is a weak
weak
weak weak little boy
a weak little boy gabe he's a weak
little boy
so weak oh my god
so
i and i told the audience this earlier
uh you've been making the uh the bone
hint of the week you've been getting it
together so i don't know listening but i
told him earlier that i actually we were
doing the production
um midas touch they made the um the
video run holly run the bra
which i'm gonna i'm gonna play several
more times because yeah yeah i mean i
have it i've had it in my head all
morning
but i had not i had not
watched that video yet and it is
absolutely
hilarious there are there are some
pretty fun like i've seen one thread
specifically from one person and they
keep putting that video to different
soundtracks or like just different music
right
and for anyone who watches uh stranger
things there's a song there's one like
but this person used that uh
the katy bush song the one
that's that's
is played throughout this whole past
season
um so that made me laugh uh but there's
also a ton of other there's like
like it's all it's it's too good anyway
uh i think there's to be a lot of
content a lot of content
about josh holly running well here's the
thing it is there is a i mean he's in
office until like 2025 i think or that's
like when he's up for re-election so
he's got a bit of time to kind of
run away from his past
yeah you know and i asked this one and i
was like do you think that josh hawley
will run for or run from office again
you know
and uh i don't know you know it is one
of those things but i hope to god that
people keep pushing this [ __ ] because
again
it is an amazing moment
and it is one in which you totally call
out the hypocrisy
of
someone from this republican party who's
like a macho man
you know mega man let's go you know you
got the you got the maggot king who
can't say the word yesterday he's like
oh yesterday's too hard for me can't do
it right cut that cut that word i can't
say that he's like
like in one of the he's like vote
like he it's just a good thing there
wasn't a ketchup bottle sitting on the
podium no can you imagine oh my god like
i'm sure i'm sure paulie teaks will make
some video that has where he goes like
this and the ketchup is squirting above
and if he doesn't i'm sure someone else
will because i'll put it out there in
the ether and so i'm sure
somebody will make that content paulie
teaks listen
we need we need some video content some
ketchup right video content i've had a
couple there's been a couple ideas one
one that i threw at you this morning
yeah which i think is just i don't want
to say because then someone else is
going to do it so i'm going to wait you
can't
you know our audience our audience is
getting bigger and bigger and bigger so
the moment when you say something it
spreads like wildfire even you know even
i mean like you know months ago there
were a couple ideas that i threw out
there and then somebody
boom i can't say this stuff on the air
anymore before we go before we got off
the air someone had someone had snagged
it right we've we've got a lot of video
to watch and and i want to i want to
play the outtake video yeah over and
over and over again but we're going to
play it once and we're going to play it
in bone end of the week because
we do have a special family affair over
at bone end of the week um this week so
let's do this let's go to a break
and then when we come back we'll start
we'll just go through the bone end of
the week why not we'll be right back
with bonehead of the week right after
these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part and blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
it's friday it's the second hour
that means bone end of the week
it's the poll where you vote you decide
who is the bone end of the week
and we break it down for you
every single friday
right here on bone end of the week
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week what a great what a i i love
bonehead i absolutely love this segment
i think everyone else does too i mean
it's a fun segment you know it is why
why not
[ __ ] on these people that's right
especially after some of the [ __ ] from
last night i mean last night oh yeah was
absolutely
um
bonkers
and and we have a special um
appearance by someone
but i have a i have a theory
about that person's trial
um and why why we
why we
got the audio from that person before
the election because of his trial
because last night it would have been
much more of a bombshell right and i
kind of floated this in in the front
rant the first 30 minutes here on the
show
and so you'll know you'll know where
we're going with this but
let's let's get let's get right into it
let's go to bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition seditious
edition
opponent of the week
we have seditious
we have a family of sedition
oh well you know
speaking of that because you put you put
booger sugar junior as i refer to him
donald trump jr on this
on this
this docket
this ballot as it were for bonehead of
the week
and it's funny because that it's like
the first time last night was the first
time we actually heard from donald trump
jr right and that's what i was saying
during the hearing last night is like we
have only begun to hear from certain
people we have hours and hours of i mean
like you know pat sipoloni patrick byrne
the ex-ceo of overstock just was in
there for eight hours behind closed
doors they have a ton
of [ __ ] footage of these people
asking them questions getting the
answers either them you know saying the
fifth or i've got executive privilege or
whatever it might be we have hours of
them
giving a deposition
under oath
don jr
just made his appearance in the finale
and i wouldn't be surprised if he makes
additional cameos
throughout the next season
so we've got new witnesses which means
we got new co-stars new guest stars we
got new people we got a recurring cast
season two is about to be lit when we
come back
um
so yeah i'm super excited but you know
like i said stephen miller just made an
appearance in the in the seventh one uh
donald trump jr made an appearance in
the eighth one i think these people are
going to be coming back but you know you
couldn't
you couldn't uh introduce all of them at
the same time right you know so
well that's a good point because we on
our broadcast last night we went to
jamie raskin he was front of a
microphone after the fact and he was
talking about that there was almost an
hour of outtakes
um that they had to go through and they
chose the outtakes and we're going to
show those outtakes so i don't know if
those outtakes were the best or the
worst outrage right
right they had to be like we got to pick
the best we got we got to pick the
perfect because well here i'm sure that
they picked the most embarrassing ones
rightfully so you want to [ __ ] drag
this guy through the [ __ ] mud as much
as possible in front of millions on a
prime time television slot that's the
goal
you guys did a great job
right right well and and we'll get to
that tape right and and that has to do
with our other bonehead ivanka but back
to donald trump jr here for just one
second because i want to show
what sort of the
because there was only really one
question
that donald trump jr kind of answered
and it was about his text to mark
meadows here right donald trump jr text
on the six at 2 53
he says he's got to condemn this [ __ ]
asap the capitol police tweet is not
enough and we've we've seen that tweet
before yeah yeah this one this one was
introduced by liz cheney months ago
before they even started these hearings
they had a couple of the under uh like
initial ones
and they read everything from his to fox
news
right mark metals responds in this tweet
thread
i am pushing it hard i agree and then
the next statement is the statement that
they actually asked the question about
right that no one has seen yet this is
the first time they're introducing this
so this text message here donald trump
jr writes and and you gotta you gotta
see the tick tock here so 253 he sends
the tweet
mark meadows text him back within a
minute
yeah and then within four minutes donald
trump jr booger sugar junior
text
mark meadows back this statement
this
is one you go to the mattress on
this i think he meant to say this is
yeah but he said this his i mean you
know i mean when you're doing between
lines you know and you're trying to get
a little right and he won't answer
you're like ugh uh this is one you go to
the mattresses on right well maybe he
did the maybe he he he snorted through
his coke spoon on the his and the is
but this is one that you go to the
mattresses on
i've never heard it said like that i'll
get back in a second they will try to
[ __ ] his entire legacy on this if it
gets worse no no no no not they dummy
not you know i i love how these [ __ ]
they they talk about pronouns they hate
pronouns [ __ ] pronouns [ __ ] pronouns
but in this here he's using pronouns as
a blanket of they who the [ __ ] is they
they as in donald trump himself ruining
his entire legacy but he did that right
he [ __ ] around and now
they are finding out but like yeah it's
like oh you guys you know the [ __ ]
pronoun thing is like yeah you could
easily use they you could easily use
they but you get all [ __ ] up and
tight and triggered because you don't
want to call because someone's like hey
i don't go by he or she i go by they
them or something like that and and it's
like oh my god i've never used they dem
ever in my life and here he is now i'm
gonna do yeah here he is in the middle
of the coup saying they
will [ __ ] his entire legacy if this gets
worse no no you guys [ __ ] your entire
legacy you keep doing this stuff like
they're still doing it to this day
they're still doing this [ __ ] well this
is also not the first time we saw i
think the legacy talk came in
uh laura ingraham's text right and she
said or maybe it was sean hannity i
forget which one but one of them talked
about i know lauren laurie ingraham said
this is going to ruin it for us all or
something like that right right but one
of the two mentioned legacy oh they did
say the word
i'm almost positive they i could go i
could go back through the dramatic
reading of me
and reading the text messages i could
double check but i'm pretty sure one of
them said legacy which means it's very
funny that they look at this thing and
they say
oh this this
this time he was in office he
accomplished so much and it was of a
legacy status like no other president
had done what he has done
uh okay all right well you know i don't
know about that because i don't agree
with that at all but you look at this
and they're like oh [ __ ] if he lets this
[ __ ] go it's gonna ruin everything
everything we work for everything we try
to ruin it's gonna be even worse and
we're gonna get blamed for it
what that's what this is i mean their
their
their lack of self-awareness is
astounding oh yeah absolutely [ __ ]
astounding that they don't realize that
they were on the stage inciting these
violent people who they knew had weapons
who were ready to go to war for them and
cited them to go to the capitol and kill
the [ __ ] vice president
you had ted cruz
or whatever before saying we will not go
silently into the night you had that day
saying trump saying i'm gonna march i'm
gonna walk with you up to the capitol
down uh pennsylvania avenue rudy
giuliani trial by combat right exactly
you know we're gonna uh
who it was uh mo brooks we're gonna uh
kick their ass or whatever he said like
kick names and take ass
exactly yeah you know but he's the one
who's wearing a bulletproof vest you had
all these people who clearly knew what
they were doing they were inciting they
were instigating they were pouring
[ __ ] kerosene onto this fire
and they were prepared you know safely
from a distance or with protection
and then when [ __ ] really hit the fan
and it was not going the way that at
least people had anticipated or planned
for meaning that you know it wasn't all
antifa or blm and and the oath keepers
couldn't you know go in and uh and have
martial law like all these things that
didn't go their way they're like oh [ __ ]
we now look like the incompetent
[ __ ] because trump is probably
holding out to be like
this is gonna get worse and i'm gonna
have to call these guys in and then i'm
gonna save the day like i'm gonna have
to save the day
from the [ __ ] show and the mess that i
created you know and then there is a
moment though there is a moment in this
hearing when they start to tick-tock
through the kevin mccarthy stuff which
again there's so much stuff to go
through with these hearings and we're
just seeing a tip of the iceberg but
there's a moment
when they're describing the phone call
between trump and kevin mccarthy
and
the
the moment when trump initially contacts
kevin mccarthy and says oh all these
people being violent that's antifa
right and kevin mccarthy going uh no
they're breaking into our offices my
staff is running away from your
supporters who were down at the ellipse
yeah this is your people you told them
to come here yeah
but in that moment in that moment donald
trump's instinct was to be an internet
troll like in that he's the president of
the united states yeah
he is trying to overthrow our democracy
and in that moment he is talking to them
to the minority leader of the house of
representatives kevin mccarthy no matter
how boneheaded he is he's the leader
on the phone
and he's like it's antifa like oh my god
dude why don't you just throw a pepe
meme in there too
right jesus christ
they're like oh well clearly you know
and then he's like no they're yours he's
like well i guess they want it more
badly or you know right than you do and
you're like whoa whoa okay so now it is
them so now you admit that it is exactly
but that's exactly what an internet
troll would do right that's exactly what
an internet troll would do right
it's it's i mean
if you if you were to analyze all of the
comments that you would see on any sort
of video that's calling out any sort of
policy or law making or anything that
has to do with politics right like hey
the republicans are doing this crazy
thing right it's crazy that the the
republican party is actually comprised
of a bunch of groomers despite the fact
that they're projecting their own
insecurities and their own wants and
desires
for
uh what they want to do with children
right onto the laws and policies they're
making uh for other like children and
other people of different genders
and then
you know you have that going on and
you're like well it's it's
it's just like no wonder that the party
that
yeah i don't know it's just like
this the republicans are are the are the
trolls they are the people that want to
do this and so when you look at these
comments online if you were to bring up
an actual point they would try to come
up with something like god well i saw no
in this article and you're like well
that's not actually an article or that's
an op-ed these aren't fact check
whatever and then they will default and
be like well
clearly you don't you know it's you you
are not a problem it's no longer factual
based it's you you're fat you're ugly
you're stupid you're dumb but here here
in this statement gabe right here in
this statement donald trump's doing the
same thing where he is the problem they
are the problem they did this to
themselves they worked for almost an
entire year to make sure that if he lost
they could overturn the election donald
trump even we even saw back during
election he's like oh there's different
avenues that we can take and that
they'll have to here he blames it on
they that that is going to destroy their
legacy you are the problem it's i i
tried everything i could to overthrow
the government and you're going to make
bones about it which is going to destroy
me
how dare you destroy me over what i did
it's the same thing as marjorie taylor
green getting pissed off at patriot
takes because he's clipping out her show
and posting it on twitter and it's
really [ __ ] funny right he tried to
fight it legally through absurd claims
no evidence rudy giuliani says we don't
have any evidence
we only have there is no fraud is what
he had to say in front of a judge the
republican party that are trying to say
like yeah okay fine we'll give you the
committee you want to investigate
they're like
hold on i'm sorry you don't have
anything even in the meetings that they
had on december 18th patsy bologna is
asking for evidence and people like
sydney powell was like how dare you you
should know you should know where it
came from we heard these exact things
come out of the seventh hearing the
seventh day hearing where pat said
bologna is asking these questions and
all of them are getting defensive
because they don't actually have the
evidence and so like oh well you should
know how dare you challenge my lie you
know this is a lie and you shouldn't be
challenging it because if you challenge
it it'll make it all fall apart and
that's what donald trump jr is saying
here the one thing i want to point out
on this on this text though
on the first the first part
this is one you go to the mattresses on
that's not that's how you say it you go
to the mat the the mat
stop it again remember he's between a
couple lines of coke he's stressed out
he can't get ahold of his dad ivanka
won't answer he's like where's jared you
know jared's in the shower he just came
back from a trip
you know it's all these things that uh
i do want to point out actually
something that was very funny i had my
own suspicions that jared i know that he
was out of town and then he came back
into town that day and i knew i was like
there is no [ __ ] way that all of this
[ __ ] went down and he was not involved
in some way and when i and i don't
remember but when i made that anonymous
staffer video which was like oh hey the
seven hours of like gap in time of of
who was coming in who's coming out in
the 187 minutes
i bring up jared kushner and i talk
about jared kushner was one of the
people that tried to
uh get get trump to [ __ ] calm down
and make an announcement and people came
at me and they're like jared kushner was
out of town
and i didn't have it i didn't have a
different like definitive answer to be
like oh he was in fact in town and was
available and this hearing
just proved my video right which was he
was in town and he was directly
contacted
to try to influence trump to be like hey
you might want to
calm the [ __ ] troops here
that you've got on the steps of the
capitol
well that's
and the thing the funniest part about
kushner and i'll go to ivanka here right
um
is
we found out he was taking a shower
during the coup
i guess i guess you know that sedition
is filthy you gotta watch it
like i don't know if
he like got home from the from the
flight and i did not even see anything
happening but i find that so unlikely so
incredibly unlikely that nobody within
that group his wife especially would say
hey my dad's [ __ ] [ __ ] up a storm
right now
in the dining room he's watching fox
news he won't do [ __ ] like i have i have
a very hard time not only that but
anyone else that's like hey jared you
have an inside track to this guy can you
do something we find out later that
actually that was the case right and
they were trying to communicate with
them but like i have a very hard time
believing that you'll be like oh [ __ ]
i'm going to leave from my flight
and go deal with this as opposed to you
know what
let me just turn the water on and let
the bathroom steam up a little bit you
know make myself a little relaxed but
but wouldn't the shower hurt his his uh
android parts or he's probably i mean
i'm sure that before he goes into the
shower he like lathers on some sort of
like
uh vaseline or something to make sure he
doesn't
you know to protect the robot
yeah he's not an advanced you know kind
of i don't know if they make i don't
know if they make uh
waterproof bots these days or humanoids
um i don't know if they make those water
i mean i do know that little dolls like
the little doll from the movie uh
definitely water can seep in and they
can ruin the parts for sure you know
maybe that's maybe that's why he just
was standing outside the shower to make
people think he actually does shower i
don't think if anyone out there is
listening i am in fact taking a shower
right now i am a human i am a human this
shower feels so good
speaking of uh jared kushner his wife
ivanka trump um they tried
they were trying to get anyone
absolutely anyone in the room with the
cheeto dust mobster with grandpa poopy
pants to convince him that hey this is a
really shitty a really shitty look
you went out and you incited them to
commit violence and to go kill mike
pence and that's what they're going to
do right um
and here is a here's a clip of uh
that weak piece of [ __ ] patsy bologna
um
the pregnant pauses he has and some of
these answers is so telling it's gross
it's really gross but here he is
describing
trying to get ivanka and ivanka even
failing in her first attempt of trying
to get grandpa poopypants to call off
the mob
an immediate
and forceful
response statement public statement that
people need to lead the capital now
my question is exactly that that sounds
like you from the very offset of
violence at the capitol
right around two o'clock
we're pushing for a strong statement
that people should leave the capital is
that right
i was another sort or so pat you said
that you expressed your opinion
forcefully
could you
tell us exactly how you did that
yeah i can't i'm i'm don't have you know
i have to uh
i can get on this issue i can't talk
about conversation what a [ __ ] little
dumb
dude the fact that he's like oh i
the question was what did you do
right to to deal with this right how did
you handle how did you approach him
right
he's not revealing anything that's
private like it's not like oh [ __ ] trump
said this well but but here's the thing
here's the thing here's what i believe
here's what i believe patsy bologna is
invoking privilege where the crime is
committed and pat cipollone knows it oh
yeah yeah pat sipoloni knows that's
where if he says this [ __ ] out loud
under oath it is not only possible that
that donald trump will be will be
possibly criminally liable for his
actions but possibly pits patsy bologna
in that moment knowing he's part of it
right
and i'm sure his lawyers like you know
he's already gone through this he had to
go through a tick tock himself with the
lawyers to be like all right cool so
this is what actually happened right
right like i will tell you to the
down to the minute what i said what i
did and what he did in response
and the lawyer obviously throughout many
of these clips you see the lawyer you
know
yeah he's like elbowing him like hey
he's up he's up he's up
that's gonna that's gonna that's criming
that's criming well and that's the thing
here is that like you said the this
attorney who was sitting with him they
they went through the tick tock
line by line by line
and they they took a marker you know
maybe a sharpie or something drawing you
know uh circles on a map but they took a
sharpie and they said nope can't say
that oh you can't say that can't say
that oh yeah can't say that can't say
that can't say that here's the thing
though
and this is what everyone should realize
is the committee knows all this stuff
the committee knows what the
conversation was the committee knows
what was happening in those rooms that's
why they're asking pat sipolon these
questions that's why patsy bologna has
to say privilege privilege privilege
that piece of [ __ ] but let's listen to
him describe
how because he's trying he's trying to
undo the coup
pat simpolonius because what pat
sepaloni understands that if he's a part
of it he's going to go to [ __ ] prison
right and pastor bologna still may have
criminal liability here this doesn't
exonerate him by going and and and
giving testimony yeah to this remember
you know dave this is just the first
time that's right come in so they may
after getting some well but it doesn't
mean that the department of justice
won't try to charge him exactly just
because he participated i mean even even
sarah matthews and cassidy hutchinson uh
any of these people who are uh the the
matthew pottinger any of these people
are trying to absolve themselves of any
kind of criminal liability or at least
in at the bare minimum right to seem
cooperative that way in case prosecutors
they become a target now listen to what
what it's it's [ __ ] it's astounding
that the white house staff
is trying to find the pretty daughter to
go in
to convince
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopypants to call off his coup attempt
it is [ __ ] insane well they i mean
that's the thing everybody knows her
influence on him i mean we see that well
yeah we're going to see it in the clip
of the um
of of the outtakes on january 7th yeah
that i said you know
people need to be told there needs to be
a public announcement
fast
that they need to leave the capitol
and pat could you let us know
approximately when you said that
approximately when almost immediately
after i found out people were getting
into the capital or
approaching the capital in a way that
was
was violent
do you remember any discussion with mark
meadows with respect to
his view that the president didn't want
to do anything
i want to go back for a second before
the mark meadow stuff
pat cipollone is admitting there that as
soon as he knew right
he
listen to what he's saying as soon as he
knew
that the people had entered the capitol
and they were being quote his words
violent
that he went to push the president to
make a statement so the
donald trump sitting in the dining room
watching the tv pat sipoloni comes in he
is the white house counsel
telling the president united states it
is now violent you have to call them off
right
donald trump knew that this was a
violent insurrection from the moment
that it became violent there is no way
in hell that he did not know and he did
nothing well if you remember the
timeline right he leaves the stage gets
into the suv there's the tussle where he
try he has his tantrum and wants to go
to the capitol they say no after some
back and forth and trying to choke the
secret service agent they say you're in
timeout we're going to the cap or we're
going to uh the white house they take
him to the white house the photo that
they showed was at minute 11. within the
first 15 minutes of him leaving the
stage
he knew the capital was under attack
if trump knew that the capital was under
attack within 15 minutes pat said
bologna knew within probably 10 minutes
you know so to have to have it's like
there's no way or if it was really okay
they found at the same time right
everyone's like oh [ __ ] they're storming
the capital and there's violence
remember at 1 49
when trump tweets out his
narcissistic uh video of him giving a
speech at the ellipse
mpd says this is now a riot we are
classifying this right over the radio
over the radio they knew what it was the
tick tock of when the tweets go out and
when the announcements or or attempts to
to calm trump are happening
he's tweeting about something unrelated
something else
you know what we should do we should get
someone who's really good at graphic art
to like give a timeline to show
i'm just saying i'm just saying okay
let's let's listen to what pat cibolone
says about getting ivanka to try to go
um calm down
the the man-child and get him to call
off his
his army of insurrectionist so your
advice was tell people in the capital
and that took
over two hours when there were
subsequent statements made tweets put
forth that in your view were
insufficient did you continue simple
money throughout the period of time
up until 417 continue you and others to
push for a stronger state
were you joined in that effort by ivanka
trump yes eric hershey yes by mark
meadow yes
so there it is yes yes yes ivanka trump
helped me
he helped she she helped me so monica
trump she ends up on the bone of the
week because she couldn't go talk down
the man child that is her handsy father
she couldn't yep couldn't get couldn't
get daddy trump to come calm the [ __ ]
storm could you know couldn't get him to
call off the mob i want to go to before
we go to our winner of course everyone
knows who the winner is because it was
like oh my god right out of the gate he
was dude he ran fast and holly down the
hallway okay speak speaking of holly and
running
josh holly
of the week josh holly um obviously it's
because of
right i mean so deserving of the man who
literally sells merchandise
with his very proud he's very proud of
that oh yeah let's go seditionist yeah
[ __ ] oh man storm the capital he's
there in you know he's like i'm with you
i would he's like look if i didn't have
to do my job i would totally be storming
the capitol with you you know something
something a good point that susie made
last night on the um
on the panel before the show was yeah
the identification between a democratic
representative and a republican
representative
these people who stormed the capitol and
saw red in their eyes would not be able
to tell the difference you know they
they don't know the difference oh he's
he's a democrat he's a republican right
right you look at well
some of the democrats would not be able
to hide
right some of the democrats would not be
able to hide who they are i mean they
knew i clearly know like oh that's
that's who this is right but you have to
remember that again well but here's the
thing
you can't you can't you the democratic
members who are people of color
oh yeah
who
they could not just take off their pen
their democrat pen right yeah they can't
take it off
um they would know who they were
and that well i mean especially when you
know at all of the republican party
vilifies them
as the enemy right oh look at these
people these groomers these blood
whatever you know they try to make all
these things up or really again they're
hiding their own insecurities their own
projections onto them i mean you have to
remember there's a clip they didn't show
it at all during um
during these hearings but there's a clip
of them inside the chambers
and they're going through papers
and they they find ted cruz's papers
and they get so upset and so angry
because what they are unable to
comprehend right it seems like reading
and comprehension is a big thing a big
problem for trumpers because in the
moment they look at it and they get so
mad and they believe that ted cruz
was not
going to certify
or or rather was going to certify and be
against them right so they're like oh no
ted cruz
they got also all flustered and then
somebody comes over and like no no no no
no this means that he's not he's not
gonna certify
and he's on our side he's on our side
he's on our side but it it's like
but they're searching for them they're
searching for it's not on their side
they are looking at the time that's why
you have they are but yeah
that's why you have josh hawley running
away from them after he incited him and
it's not just the fist pump right
because that's the imagery but this is
the very first sitting united states
center that went on the airwaves and
started to talk about this boneheaded
idea that the [ __ ] vice president
united states has the power to to crown
trump king and they can have fake
electors and who knows what's going to
happen anything could happen and the
certification he kept saying [ __ ] like
that which is not the truth even brett
bear if you can find that clip for me
josh hawley and brett bear and i think
it's a couple days before january 6th
he bret bear is like you are a dumb [ __ ]
that is not even close to how it works
you are lying and that's on fox news but
the first video i want to show josh
holly and i'm going to have to play it a
couple times because i just can't resist
this is midas touch's version
of run holly run
[Music]
the he's the [ __ ] laughing stock
capitol hill right now
here's the thing here's the thing forget
no one will forget him running away
like a chicken [ __ ] that he is
but here's the thing he's not just a
laughing stock in washington this
morning
in missouri yeah in missouri on am radio
i'm talking deep red trump country right
wing radio talk radio
and they have local hosts that say [ __ ]
steve bannon wouldn't even say
in that in in that
in that universe in that ecosphere this
morning they are running news reports
and they're not good about josh in
missouri
good about how he's a weak piece of [ __ ]
right i mean people said people said oh
what's the point of these hearings
they're not gonna do anything again
there are people who did not know what
was happening on january 6 because
they're you know out of the loop and
they're just hearing about it they did
not know that or they were under the
belief that this was all made up because
of people like josh hawley and others
who were denying it
but the fact that you begin to see the
needle move in the direction of people
saying oh [ __ ] trump
trump should have done something
that was totally wrong of him
or he was behind it or at least he was
inciting this group
and kind of prodding them to get ready
and then he let them loose on on the
capitol
you know on on the on the blue on the
police that everyone whatever one of
these uh republicans love to claim that
they that they adore right
um so the fact that people are turning
on him in missouri the state that he
doesn't live in of course but he
represents
oh we all know amazing that is amazing
news
well it's incredible it's incredible but
here here is this is from january 4th
this is two days before the insurrection
and this is josh hawley on fox news
let's listen so the supreme court didn't
take up that that case either they did
not take up the quick case the supreme
court we've seen courts across the
country deal not only with not the
standing of different cases but also the
evidence and some of them trump's trump
judges i just want to pin you down on on
what you're trying to do you know
are you trying to say that as of january
20th that president trump will be
president
well that that depends on what happens
on wednesday i mean this is why we have
the debate no this is why we have that
and bret baer jumps in right there no it
doesn't no it does not matter what
happens on wednesday it's already
certified that's what i
argued from the very beginning this
delusional idea that the vice president
has any other power but to swing the
gavel and to have this ceremony to where
they they read the [ __ ] name on the
envelopes or not israel is
redundant at best but it's ridiculous
that you would have that you would have
the power of the vice president those
votes are already certified by the state
is what makes joe biden the
president-elect is what gives the actual
chief justice of the supreme court the
ability and the legal authority to swear
in that person that the state certified
as president united states on january
20th at noon yeah it's absolutely
[ __ ] money tony what happened to
states rights though man right yeah well
yeah that's right
they depend to have the control over
their own elections yeah but it depends
it depends on what their narrative is in
the moment gabe one day it's this one
day it's uh right you know i i this is
another example of someone
uh where
you don't need to be smart to go to an
ivy league school just saying this guy
went to stanford he went to yale he was
the attorney general of missouri and
this guy doesn't know [ __ ] he's an elite
about laws he's an elite he is an elite
through and through lives in [ __ ]
virginia lives in virginia and living
[ __ ] missouri's he's from is
everybody in live in missouri in years
he had a [ __ ] he had to [ __ ] rent
a house
here so that he can run for attorney
general because you can't be the
attorney general without living here
right he had to rent a house just same
way mark mark meadows ran a [ __ ]
trailer in in north carolina or south
carolina where the [ __ ] it was so he
could vote right yeah which sounds
pretty similar to what you know people
like uh dr oz and herschel walker all
right they live in different states but
they have this other home or residence
that they claim you know but they're
like okay
i drove into the state to get gas so i
was there right right that's i call i
call back to the state every once in
awhile so that makes me you know
eligible right let's listen let's listen
to how because bret bear does not let
him up here states by the constitution
say they certify the election they did
certify it by the constitution congress
doesn't have the right to overturn the
certification at least as most experts
read it
well congress is is directed under the
12th amendment to count the electoral
votes there's a statute that dates back
to the 19th what in the [ __ ] the word
count means that you get to to count
differently right
these people you cannot miss it like it
is a count to say it really this is
binary it is either one or zero this or
that it was either trump or biden or
possibly some other third party
candidate but at the end of the day it's
not like you can say well the vote for
biden the way that i see it actually
means a vote for trump it doesn't work
that way you can't just reassign votes
to someone else but that's the that's
the context here because this is two
days before this is happening right and
they're wanting they're wanting these
people to come they're wanting to show
they want to be at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life they don't
want government they don't want policy
they don't want to be serious about it
they only want fascism because it's
super easy for one person or a couple
people to wave a fascist wand and tell
you what the [ __ ] to do what to think
who to be where to be and you ain't got
no say in it that's what they want
that's what they've always wanted that's
what this [ __ ] nazi wants because
that's what he is he's a [ __ ] ninja
poop nazi
to the 1800s rather 19th century that
says that there is a right to object
there's a right to be heard and there's
also certification right that's from
1876 senator and it's it's the
tilden hayes race in which there were
three states that did not certify their
electors so congress was left to come up
with this system this commission that
eventually got to a negotiated grand
bargain but now all of the states have
certified their elections as of december
14th so i love his face here when when
he tries to pull out history and brett
bear's like look yeah i know the history
dumb [ __ ] let me tell you how it
actually means 80s you know it's like
you know he comes in and he's like i'm
going to give you a bit of a history
lesson because he clearly didn't get it
in law school
and you clearly didn't keep up with it
even though you're a sitting
senator
from the state of missouri in which you
don't live in right
so
it's it is funny it is great to see you
know those moments where foxy is like oh
actually okay i'm going to call [ __ ]
like i'll believe this crazy conspiracy
to an extent
but let's let's call it what it is right
because what you're doing right now is
you're spreading
it's disinformation right you're
intentionally spreading this false
narrative so that people will run with
it you know probably the same way in
which you ran down the hall but
you know that they run with it
and they will do whatever they can and i
i think you've got a i think you might
play a video of are you going for the
capitol outside the capitol no no i'm
going for the uh here it is the laughter
in the room oh right now this is this is
uh the great um a great piece
because again last night when we were
doing the production
when when the video is playing the
production shuts the mics off in the
room yeah so you can't he the room is
not miked when the video is playing
right so you couldn't hear it through
the headphones you couldn't hear it
through the sound but when it cut back
to sarah matthews and she was smirking
and everyone behind her was laughing i i
text i was like hey they're all laughing
they're all laughing
so i knew that this had to exist
somewhere from inside the room and here
is here is the reaction to this video of
josh holly running inside the room and
then we'll go to the dishonorable
mention
[Music]
they're like hold for audience laughter
hold for audience laughter
okay
like that
whole that i mean like this is a moment
that we would not know happened unless
we had people in the room who were like
oh i'm documenting this [ __ ]
historical moment right
which is what makes a complete fool yeah
a complete fool and a josh hawley
speaking of complete bulls and last
night was one of his first experi
entrances too we've heard his name in
the hearings but we haven't heard from
him yet because he he is held in
contempt because he he wouldn't be
deposed he refused and that's why he's
on criminal trial for contempt of
congress
scabby steve bannon boy you picked a
good one there for him look i always i
make sure to put these people in the
best light possible so this
was the best
photo
i'm just telling you this was the best
photo i could find of steve bannon we're
trying to do him a favor here huh yeah
well so
here's my theory
because mueller she wrote let me see if
i can find this uh this tweet this
morning she surmised uh i i noticed on
on twitter
um allison surmised that hey
they playing the audio of steve bannon
last night he might try to use that in
court
and i got to thinking about it this
morning i'm like you know maybe she's
right because steve bannon you know is a
low-life piece of [ __ ] yeah he'll use
any kind of excuse he can
absolutely any
and
and then i thought a little more about
it i'm like well maybe not because he
really hasn't put together a defense at
all and the reason why is i think the
reason why we talked about yesterday
was that
steve bannon can't do these antics in
this court
the judge is not having it right the
reason why is because it when because he
thinks he's going to get convicted right
and if he gets convicted
then when they go to sentence him he
doesn't want that to be on the court
record that he was causing havoc in in
the courtroom with a bunch of [ __ ]
right because he wants to try to receive
the lowest sentence possible here
because he knows he's going to be
convicted
um because he's going all in without a
plea deal here because it's a
misdemeanor right now mueller she wrote
um put on twitter this morning cheney
bringing up bannon audio that recently
leaked i hope this doesn't taint the
bannon jury
no way bannon doesn't bring this up so
what she's saying here is that bannon
can make the argument that it taints the
jury
which um
the judge could or could not decide that
that's the truth i likely would say the
judge would say well [ __ ] that here's
why i think the judge would say that the
judge would say well this tape has
existed before the trial right this tape
has existed on the internet before the
trial so why wouldn't the january now if
you think about that we played that tape
the other day and maybe we should bring
that up too to play that for everybody
um but here's the thing
that tape
was leaked what was it last week or was
it beginning of this week it was some
time
yeah it was before the trial
so if you really think about it if if
the january 6th elect committee thought
you know bannon's gonna you know that
trial moved very quickly and this is
them thinking on their feet
this is the the people who are producing
the show who are putting the clips
together
who who know everything in real time
what the news is happening who's being
prosecuted where they're like look steve
bannon is gonna be in court next week
and if we play this tape because gabe
can you even [ __ ] imagine
the [ __ ] sonic waves that would have
happened last night if no one would have
heard that ban tape before that here i
mean it would have been like holy actual
[ __ ]
if no one had heard that tape before but
he heard that tape because it had been
released right it had it existed since
2020 it was released last week they
reiterated so i have i you know i'm not
a lawyer or anything but i do have a
hard time believing that it would taint
the trial in any way
and that it wasn't just like they were
playing it for the first time or they
were trying you know it wasn't like they
were like oh i'm going to disparage this
person's character right it's just him
they're just like he said this stuff he
knew what was going to happen right and
so he was joking about it people
laughing but allison's point to
allison's point she's making the point
that that bannon could say it tainted
the jury not the evidence the jury which
because the judges told the jury not to
watch this stuff
now if they know that and the select
committee's like oh my god we got this
big piece of evidence and it might
affect that trial but we have to put
this out in the public maybe maybe maybe
it just i don't know
it worked its hands in the ways of
mother jones and here is mother jones's
version
of this audio tape let's listen and what
trump's gonna do is just declare victory
right he's going to declare a victory
but that doesn't mean he's the winner
he's just going to save the winner
[Music]
the democrats
more of our people vote
early that count they're voted mail and
so they're going to have a natural
disadvantage and trump's going to take
advantage of it that's our strategy he's
going to clear himself a winner so when
you wake up wednesday morning
it's going to be a firestorm
gonna have a t for crazy the media crazy
the courts are crazy and trump's gonna
be sitting there mocking tweeting [ __ ]
out you lose
i'm the winner i'm the king
and he'll be all over hillary he'll be
going where's hunters hunter on a crack
pipe i mean no he'll be because then it
doesn't matter remember
here's the thing after that trump never
has to go to a voter again
he's going to fire ray the fbi director
before the scene and say [ __ ] you how
about that because he's never gonna he's
he's done his last election oh he's
gonna be off the chase
also if trump is if trump is losing
like 10 or 11 o'clock at night
it's going to be even crazier
no because
i'm directing the attorney general
to shut down all ballot places in all 50
states it's going to be enough he's not
going out easy if biden's winning
trump is going to do some crazy [ __ ]
so there you have it there's the tape
that they they put out last night and
you'd be the judge of this but i believe
that possibly this thing was
was leaked out
so that the public could hear it
beforehand so that bannon couldn't make
this claim that oh it's they're trying
to taint my jury right they're trying
the select committee is trying to come
after me no man
they wanted you to come in and testify
to this stuff because here's the thing
the committee had this tape
why do you think steve bannon didn't
want to come in and be deposed about
this [ __ ] tape yeah that's that's the
rub that's what it is is it getting i
mean
there's no you know for anyone who's
like oh look at these people they don't
know what they're talking about or look
at these liberals or whatever it's like
there's no way that you can with a
straight face say if steve bannon was in
that hall
and they played that tape and they said
can you explain what you mean by this
if your only response is that he says oh
it was a joke it was a joke because
that's all you have that's the only
defense that somebody has to be like
okay that doesn't sound great because
what he's admitting to is what trump did
right which means that within some
circles
somebody was discussing this already
whether via bannon or someone else
but if you're trying to be like oh it
was just a joke it's just a joke it
doesn't i don't think it's a i don't
think it plays well to either side of
this
which is
you either say that this guy has been
joking the whole time he doesn't know
what he's talking about or you say that
they were planning this thing
from before
january 6 which only adds to the
narrative that these guys are trying to
overthrow the government it is and steve
bannon our dishonorable mention this
week
for bone end of the week let's move back
to our contestants and to the winner
donald j trump himself the cheetos
mobster i didn't know if we don't have
to call him the former guy anymore we
don't have to call him i mean you know
you don't have to acknowledge that he
was even the president of this [ __ ]
trader
he committed treason as far as i'm
concerned he knew that these people were
going to the capitol for war that's what
he wanted him there for
and he intentionally did not stop him
for that reason
but just watched from the dining room
watched fox news like you know he's like
oh god but the piece of video evidence
gabe
that ties ivanka trump our other
contestant and donald trump together
here
is the the tape of the day after where
you would expect him to have a little
bit of remorse about this right but he
doesn't no and he and he's still the
whiny little [ __ ] though he's like he's
like i didn't do anything wrong what did
i do wrong guys
but remember if he admitted
to the people doing wrong right to these
were my people then it would be him
admitting to fault that he was the one
who brought them there and they were the
ones that caused the damage which means
that he was the one that caused the
damage to be done
through his
speech through his tweet through his
just
non-stop incessant of obsession
with
uh trying to overturn the election right
because he lost
and he doesn't want to admit it because
there's a lot of things that happen
to donald trump when he admits he lost
and he even does it in this tape here is
the outtakes
from the statement he's trying to put
together on the day after
the violent insurrection where he tried
to attempt a cheeto dust kangaroo coup
here's him in the outtakes whenever
you're ready
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
and to those who broke the law
you will pay
you do not represent our movement you do
not represent our country
and if you broke the law
you can't say that
i'm not you i already said you will pay
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defied the seat of decisions
defiled right see i can't see it very
well okay i'll do this i'm going to do
this let's go but this election is now
over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election's over i
just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
now congress yeah right now congress i
didn't say over so let me see
don't go to the paragraph before
okay
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
yesterday's a hard word for me
ah good take the word yesterday because
it doesn't work with
the heinous attack
on our country say on our country want
to say that
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
yesterday yesterday yesterday yesterday
yesterday yes yesterday easter easter
easter easter day
is a hard word for me
what a
dude
we already know that trump has a very
limited
vocabulary right he goes through these
same types of words with some fillers in
between well you know you know that
that's what actually works with his
supporters that's the thing that's the
thing that draws them very basic right
well because because it doesn't take a
lot of brain power to try to actually
project
what you want to believe from his words
right right that that's why and and i
don't think it's intentional from him he
stumbles into this right yeah he's like
the pied piper of dumb [ __ ] right but
he but he what
what
he is he's a piper dumbbell
but but i mean this this simple talk
these simple words that the the
dumbed-down vocabulary that he already
has right this is doing it for his
supporters he's not doing it
intentionally this is him and it's
because they're able to take his stupid
[ __ ] broad-stroked words
which most the time he's playing both
sides of the fence as he was in here
he's like no i don't want to call them
criminals but i have to say we're going
to send them the prison right like dude
you said that why why i don't want to
say i lost but i want to say congress
certified like those that's the same
[ __ ] ivanka is like but they cert but
they certified right and and they
certified he goes yeah i know but and
there's like but i don't certify but i
don't want to say i don't want to sail
off please don't please don't make me
sail but i mean that's the thing is he's
always able to dumb [ __ ] down and say
things but both sides of the fence well
i mean literally his supporters can
project anything they want onto his
words well i mean if you remember
supporters they're always like well why
did you vote for trump well he tells it
as it is he's just like me
i guess he sounds like you or use the
same vocabulary i don't know but like
you look at this thing right because
right now
what the committee has done has
portrayed him in his true form right he
is incompetent he's not smart at all he
has a limited set of vocabulary he's
very easily frustrated he is very
focused on his own image and how people
perceive him and these videos you can't
deny me like oh this is a deep fake you
cannot deny these videos
it's not like it's not like the gop uh
twitter account being like this is all
hearsay this is all hearsay these aren't
stories or these are just stories
they're not facts like that's how they
respond clearly if you look at that feed
of people are of that to of the uh gop
twitter account last night right they
are [ __ ] just freaking out what hell
on true social and i i know we we we're
on true social so you don't have to
right exactly but he was losing his
everlasting [ __ ] online comedian
nancy pelosi
and here's this video of democrats
saying this and he it was like every
eight minutes yeah he's gotta throw the
hillary [ __ ] in he's gotta throw the
email lady in every time he's like oh
illegitimate president this is like well
i mean hunter buttons laptop hunter
buttons laptop like they're running
around like
listen
there is only one fact that remains
is that he lost
he didn't want to lose and he was going
to do absolutely everything to overturn
our vote in our country in our democracy
right so he didn't have to admit that he
lost that's just the reason why he's the
[ __ ] bonehead of the week right that
is why and he's the bonehead of the
[ __ ] century as far as i'm concerned
yeah but this week and we don't he he
doesn't even end up on our bonehead that
often which is kind of surprising third
time yeah it's kind of surprising since
yeah
end of last year like eight months like
eight months and he has not ended up
like three well i mean yeah i mean he's
but he's not on there that much no no
not at all i mean look we could put them
on there every single [ __ ] absolutely
for sure right i mean people even write
in like trump should be on here you know
we need to vote for more people plus
trump you know like
it's one of those things where yeah we
could put him on every week because he
is the bonehead like he's just like
always had you know he is the
he's not a mega king but he is a
bonehead king right like oh sir you
dropped this crown that is
king
king
he will always be the bonehead for sure
but he's only been on here a few times
because there are tons of other people
that need to be highlighted you know we
have some other people who are on the up
and up
trying to make their ways into saying
the dumbest [ __ ] possible the most
boneheaded thing possible whatever they
try to do or whatever they try to act
like there will always be someone and so
like trump will always be off to the
side with his own bonehead king you know
the don himself the baby with the
ketchup on the wall like it'll all he'll
always be there don't worry but
sometimes he does make an appearance and
that this week was kind of necessary
well let's give him his due the bonehead
of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh our graphics depart you need to call
the graphics department that is a goof
on me i mean here's the thing
i'm switching nope i'm switching the
bone end of the week right now i'm
switching it from donald trump to gabe
sanchez oh man
this is what happens i was like trying
to do much oh that's hilarious
i always go through it so so the audio
is going to reflect here that that
representative jim jordan's face came up
and gabe is going to try to get me to
change this thing he's like no no i'm
going to send the real video
please put it on top and i'm not going
to do it i'm not going to do it i'm
going to show i'm going to show that
there is a a second inch in here
a bonehead of the week
so here's what we're going to do
oops my bad
i want to apologize to everyone go to
twitter go to twitter
at tony michael's pod vote for bonehead
of the week make sure to subscribe to
the youtube channel you can vote there
as well
don't forget to vote every single week
for bone of the week and join us in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
for bonehead of the week we do it every
single friday as we broadcast every
single weekday yeah monday through
friday
noon eastern 11 central on youtube
twitter twitch and simulcast from the
midas touch facebook page
and we also put this up on their all
directory so you can download bonehead
of the week on sunday in and of itself
yeah that is this week's bonehead of the
week stick around we have some
announcements and this week you'll have
this surprise jim jordan winner you will
you will stick around we'll have
announcements right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bone hand of the week ah look look oh
look
tony
for anyone listening you'll now know
that tony did not transition from the
bonehead of the week back to the show
segment yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna go
in and change that i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go in and change it
no no no i i think it's funny that the
jim jordan thing popped up there at the
end like oh yeah of course he's a
bonehead too sure he's always a bonehead
i mean like that was last week's winner
right and i'm sure i mean look there's
so much [ __ ] that happened this week i
can't remember what what what happened
on tuesday okay i know
uh and i would say that jim jordan
probably said or did some dumb [ __ ] oh
you know what
uh
of course he did some dumb [ __ ] i'm
trying to think like does he run any of
those
uh the the twitter accounts oh who knows
it might be that might be him that might
be him tweeting that the right the house
the house if that's the case then
boom boom
listen folks this weekend we are going
to on best of we do a best of every
saturday that is going to be the
commentary from yesterday's hearing the
prime time hearing you will hear from
susie schuster jessica denson the
mizellas brothers david bender now we
had the midas mighty favorite texas paul
gabe sanchez joined us lee mcgowan
politics girl so have you missed some of
the commentary and we had a special
guest at the very end yes yes we had
adam parker minko so
[Music]
i'm still messing it up wow
go they see they look the same go fa go
go subscribe to the youtube channel
we're just jacking this up it's a long
week this is friday we finally made it
here to the end
subscribe to the youtube channel you do
not want to miss the best of the week
and you not want to miss the bone end of
the week
so download also on apple spotify google
bonehead of the week on sunday best of
on saturday they will be there for you
regardless how much we mess up this the
end of this broadcast wow just the enemy
the dismount
together
together stumbling on the mat you know i
guess mattress i guess something on the
mattress right now as don jr would say
he's got mattresses on the mind i
think's what it is yeah so so
so
yesterday during the hearing
um you you brought up adam parkamenko he
came in at the very end um he was kind
of a surprise guest and we didn't know
he's going to come in and there's he we
did like 30 extra minutes with him so i
think what we should do right now
is thank adam for coming because it was
great commentary not just and everyone
should if you don't if you missed that
end into that hearing go watch it on the
minus touch uh networks youtube channel
or
watch best of the week because lee has
some great commentary jessica as always
in in texas paul and and david bender
always has great insight as long as
brothers we had we had um the the um
candidate that's running for city
attorney in los angeles uh heidi uh
uh feldstein soto i think is her name i
think i got it right uh suzy schuster we
had some great guests on the on the
panel so go watch that best stuff but
adam came in and was talking about
democracy and what to do how to
politicize this stuff how to make sure
to make politics out of all this
it was i think it's very valuable for
everyone to go listen to what adam says
there so go listen to that tomorrow
best of let me do it one more time make
sure i get it right subscribe to the
tony michael's podcast the channel right
here or you can go watch it right now
it's on the midas touch network's
youtube channel you can go to you can
watch the whole thing it's like five and
a half hours or you can go to that last
30 minutes where adam comes in it is
very valuable and i want to thank adam
again for coming on um and
that was kind of a surprise and i want
to thank all the guests and the hearings
have been fantastic gabe they've been
great all the guests have been great uh
i i we we've had ron reagan we've had
we've had lee mcgowan we've had malcolm
kenyatta came on um who else do we have
who am i missing i mean it's just it's
been so i mean rachel rachel bitter
copper yeah we've had
a a rotating cast of people that are on
the panel and they've all added great
wonderful commentary very insightful
things to talk about you know calling
out the hypocrisy of the republican
party but also calling out holy [ __ ]
this guy really didn't know what was
going on and he had intent to over
overturn the election uh and he you know
he let this this group of a mob
loose on our sitting
members of congress uh you know and uh
other politicians at the capitol
um and they're not done they're not done
they're not no no they're still trying
to commit a coup they're still trying to
do it
he's he's pressuring wisconsin um
they're talking about this this schedule
f i don't know if you've seen this this
morning where this executive order where
they want to fire all these federal
employees and have the authority to fire
a federal employees and install their
trumpets into our government that
they're planning on that for 2024 rather
he takes power someone else takes power
we have to be vigilant here about our
democracy we have to pay attention
that's why i think that last 30 minutes
with adam it's so important to go watch
we have to do the work of democracy
we just have to do it we have to and
stay tuned to the midas touch network
because those hearings we're going to
have more of them we're going to produce
them and we're going to get them in
september that's right and
every single weekday right every single
weekday you have to tune in here on
youtube twitter twitch and the minus
touch facebook page because we broadcast
every single weekday monday through
friday two hours noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific we will not quit as long as
you keep listening have a great
safe weekend we will see you on monday
same time same place surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking